this woman who's up next makes uh
football analysis look
very very easy when it's not the data
side of everything
her name is cynthia freeland she is from
the nfl network
data and analytics expert for the nfl
network as well as
her own clubhouse numbers game which i
think is just dynamic a lot of
people check her out for that analysis
we like to welcome
cynthia this morning early on to talk a
little nfl morning sin
good morning how are you i'm doing well
how are you
i'm doing great brockman i haven't seen
you and talk to you in so long hey
what's happening love your cute baby how
you been favorite
thank you thank you everybody loves
brockman's cute baby because it's kind
of
like a baby on the planet it's a baby
version of brockman that's why you know
that's what i've heard that's the
difference no no he's got more hair than
i've got i mean come on he's definitely
yours
[Laughter]
so um we've watched kind of this
off-season play out of course the
discussion has been around
wilson and watson where will they go but
really
uh the true numbers uh laid out
with free agent quarterbacks that
were kind of under the radar how do you
think free agency has played out in
terms of the quarterback position so far
this nfl offseason so first i don't
think we're done i think we're gonna see
some
i think deshawn watson lands in a
different spot i think we might see some
other things just totally come out of
left field some
some interesting big names that i'm
hearing are maybe on the move or
at least potentially being explored
being on the move that i haven't heard
about
until just about two weeks ago so i
don't think we're done yet but i do
think that it's been fun to see i like
where cam landed i think it's a great
fit for the patriots brockman i know i i
will we can talk and then i really like
where ryan fitzpatrick is
i think that's going to be interesting
too i think washington's the team to
beat in that division
and right now i know that dallas is like
kind of according to some people
listed as like you know the team that's
gonna win the division but i think it's
dallas
i think it's uh washington's toulouse
you know you
you referenced her there early on some
big moves i mean could you kind of give
us maybe a little bit of a hint of what
what you're hearing possibly
you know you saw a lot of people
restructuring their contracts in order
to accommodate the lowered salary cap
and that's interesting because you kind
of need to do that for many teams
because we all know like
cap dynamics are like pretty much like
this weird like black box of
you know a lot of different things that
no one understands like what's
harder to understand how the nfl cap
works or what an nft is so
those two things are kind of on par for
me right now but ultimately
you know you haven't seen some guys
restructure that you thought would
you know i just anywhere that a big name
guy that's not patrick mahomes or
you know anyone that you know because he
just did a deal last year but anyone
that's a big name that hasn't
restructured
i'm just a little like hmm what are we
what are we looking at here
that's that's kind of my that's my
that's what i've been hearing at least
what do you think about the tyreek hill
uh comments about how he he hey
i signed a contract and isn't willing
during a salary cap strapped year to
accommodate the chiefs who who have
really stood by him is that
was that was that interesting to hear
happen or are more players
apt to do that when these restructuring
asks are made in all honesty
i think that shows a reflection of
tyrique's
need to have representation that can
help him
understand how things work a little
better because the cap will go up next
season
so allowing some flexibility this season
kind of gives you a better opportunity
to you know you can restructure in a lot
of different ways
you can reflect a greater increase next
season for example
but i i don't think i think what you're
seeing here is
potentially one of the pitfalls of not
having
representation that you know i i i don't
know who his representation is but i
you know i think he's not necessarily
with ones that have helped him the most
so i think that
you know i think that he may be this
reflects the misunderstanding between
uh what the ask is and what the
potential outcomes are
we're talking to symphony cynthia
freeland from the nfl network analytics
expert
numbers game on clubhouse as the host
there as well
uh you released your mock draft 1.0 a
little while back
i wanted to kind of go through that with
you because you did you took
took a view from it from a different
angle and that was
what these teams needed in terms of
getting
more wins the next season and i had a i
had an honest-to-god question for you
in the past and you enlightened me on on
why these things are but i think our
viewer would like to know too
why don't teams draft this way anyway
because don't they want to win more
games what's the point and your answer
back was interesting i think our viewers
will
will take a lot into that sure so we
just we created a mock that was
because a lot of people like so first of
all most people insiders say like they
have to do a mock based on they kind of
call around they
it's more what they're hearing they're
reporters they're they're trying to get
it right so that a fan base can be like
okay we're really looking at so and so
or not
but we took a different approach like
when i'm talking to my editors and
how the analytics mock would go because
you know at the end of the day
i don't want to have to call people for
that because the analytics people are
not
they don't they don't make that decision
so a lot of times
what we did was figure out like all
right a lot of times like what would get
you the wins in 2021
there's free agency out there remember
this this draft the mach 1.0 came out
prior to free agency starting
there's a i'll update it next week and
with once the free agents there
are there but a lot of times people are
in different coaches and front office
members are in different cycles of their
potential contracts
some have continuity like the patriots
and so they can take a year like last
year and rebuild
other people they don't have that luxury
they get maybe two seasons at the most
to prove who they are so they've gotta
take their risk with a quarterback or
not
right and then they have to take their
risk with their pass rusher or not
and it's kind of dealing with the legacy
contracts of what was left to them
before
the mess they're in now i mean the lions
are going to be terrible
and they're not making great decisions
left and right but they have a little
bit more rope
because it's not necessarily that
they're asked to win in 2021
though i would argue that you probably
want to try to select for more wins than
you think because it's very hard
to build a culture and rebuild a culture
like keep losing keep losing keep losing
so at the end of the day it's it's
trying to navigate
where people are in their front office
climate and by the way the other thing
that thinks about
any analytics draft i would want to make
a trade at almost every position
to get it like like super like to match
the value really well like the stock
market would with a price
but we said no they would lose their
mind trying to edit that if i
if i traded out every position so so
that's how it worked out
we're talking to cynthia freeland uh
from nfl network
analytics expert numbers game on
clubhouse host as well take a look at
that
um the russell wilson talk
so i got a lot of backlash uh on
wednesday because
um i didn't think he was going anywhere
we had a uh
an expert on telling me that there's a
good possibility because of the friction
still between him and pete carroll that
that could be a possibility
jeff darlington from espn surprised me a
little bit and said there's a good
possibility that
this this move could still happen this
offseason if not for sure next season
now i
i can understand a year from now but you
know the talk continues is it just a
media concept or
are you hearing something and is that
still a possibility for somebody like
the bears or some other team out there
that could look
to make a trade to get russell wilson
this season
i don't know about the bears they don't
seem to have enough juice to be able to
get a guy like russell wilson but i do
think
anyone who's a big name who hasn't
renegotiated their contract to help
their team out
except for patrick mahomes because he
found that really team friendly deal
uh i don't think that i don't think that
anything
safe or or finalize until
until the kind of restructures come in i
think
if you're not restructuring you're not
necessarily
safe yet you're not safe to think that's
your quarterback yet am i
speaking in double speak well enough
codified language it's not good i'm a
math person not uh
not a like attempted reporter i'm not
trying to report anything but i do think
that if you haven't restructured it is
still a possibility
all right so give us uh give us bills
for our
bears fans out there some hope with andy
dalton how do you how did you like that
move from dallas as a free agent
to be qb1 now in chicago
certainly not sexy and their twitter
account can say who's qb1 but i don't
know if i believe it at all i mean we've
seen their twitter account say it before
also i think everyone most people know
like the people who are on the social
and in teams they're not that like
sitting with the gm like i don't think
ryan pace called up the twitter first
was like hey 23 year old that runs our
twitter account
please post so um you know it is what it
is i think we'll still see some things
move around i don't think the bears are
done yet by any stretch of the
imagination
and i think they got to take a swing
because i don't think they have a lot of
rope left there i mean ryan pace made
some interesting trades the trubisky one
didn't work out obviously
and so i i think they're on the chopping
block so i think when people are in the
chopping block they have to take bigger
swings
we're listening to symphony cynthia
freeland from the nfl network
um you gave brock shady here um chris
brockman a little
little high five with the uh cam newton
signing you liked that
tell us why you like that i was
surprised by it i thought he looked a
sham of himself
or a shell of himself late in the year
to see him come back
that surprised me a little bit why why
was that a good signing for you
well first of all it's the the return on
investment so number one
before covet hit he was looking great i
mean people were
like like they were caught i mean like
patriots fans could be hilarious and
they were like he's gonna be the mvp
like after tweet two yeah i wanted i
wanted to give him a hundred million
dollar contract after
three weeks after the seahawks game for
sure right for sure
i loved that that was so fun i love a
good overreaction but
so i don't think he's done yet they also
reinforced their o-line sure they lost
joe tooney to the chiefs but okay
they reinforced most of their o-line
they got two tight ends
one in line one outside you can
interchange those two that's great
they're kind of reloading in a lot of
different ways they're setting it up for
a more mobile
and to take advantage of the mobility of
cam newton
but also they're leaving themselves open
they fact his contract was peanut
it wasn't very big at all so they're
able to take what they've left over
got left over from that and they can do
a lot of different things they have
tons of flexibility and that's really
what you want to do your backups
just like everything else like if cam
newton is your potential backup and like
you could bring in you could bring in
one of these rookies and train said
rookie
you could there you have so much
flexibility and by the way
you got so much better and free agency
just all around
so you're really like it's just kind of
nothing but upside and by the way i was
looking on
the powers that because you know rich
and i like to talk about things like
that the powers that be
where where are we getting these numbers
i don't know but rich and i love it and
it's rich's show so we gotta say
like it right now some people don't
think the patriots will make the
playoffs and i say
what i think you should go tell those
people that
that's not true and you should tell them
you know the same way we tell them on
game day morning
well that would be um an interesting
afc east if the patriots are back in the
mix
this year i just when i saw the contract
and at first when it was announced like
all headlines you know 14 million
dollars i was like ah
it's a lot of money for for a guy that
that looked like he was really
struggling down the stretch but we'll
see they can make a lot of moves what
they do have to do and i
i would expect you would agree with me
is that this draft is incredibly
important because of how they've missed
the last few years in the april draft
with players like nikhil harry and the
two tight ends they drafted a year ago
because they had to go out and get two
tight ends free agency this year
see i would say that what they've done
this year more than ever
there's so much uncertainty with the
draft because you don't know what you're
getting from these players you didn't
have a regular season last year
many of the what we believe are the
consensus top players
didn't even play last season they opted
out so and which may or may not be smart
we have no idea there's no data to
support that
but what the patriots did was they
signed just like they normally do they
did spend more money than they usually
do
but what the patriots do so well is they
take a player who
we all perceive to be average or maybe a
bit above average but then
in their system they outperform all of
their contract needs so
they take the average guys use them in a
way that makes them
play above averagely that's good english
and then
ultimately win because they're just
surprising us with people we didn't even
think about
so they kind of made it so that the
draft is less
important for them it's all upside at
this point and they're not picking high
enough to like
really take a big swing and a miss
because unless you're picking in like
the top five or you're gonna trade up to
the top five we have no idea this season
it's gonna be trickier than ever and and
we don't know
many seasons there's no surefire thing
like we can pretend
that we think that trevor lawrence is
the best thing ever but until he starts
playing and
gets in the system and understands and
learns like who knows right until it
happens it happens
and there's no such thing as a sure
thing so i think what they've done is
really smart
they've minimized all of the downside of
the draft and turn it into all upside
and i'm not a patriots fan i'm not not a
patriots fan but i'm
a really big fan of their strategy this
offseason well that's good
good to hear for patriots fans out there
i got a couple questions left
uh for cynthia freeland here from the
nfl network before we get you out of
here
one tj here is a die hard cowboys fan
uh there has to be some analytics around
you know major injuries and coming back
they just gave him a back
you know the cowboys gave him a
back-breaking contract 160 million
dollars
what are the analytics around dak
prescott coming back
and being effective for this team tell
me something good cynthia you know
i didn't know i was gonna be able to
talk about joints today but i love it
jack prescott has one of those bodies
like you know look
um there's a lot of it you can you can
aggregate injury data but we all know
that like
if i get injured and if you i'm like
five foot six like and and
i don't weigh as much as you so if i get
injured and you get injured we're gonna
have different recovery
rates opportunities if someone 300 pound
hits me that's going to feel different
than if they hit you etc
so if you look at what that body is like
he has like the perfect body to come
back from an injury really strong
he's got thicker base meaning he's got
like more muscular legs hips
knees ankles and he's really got that
like nice like
he's not um he's not as fragile right a
teddy bridgewater has a more
fragile base he has a more fragile he's
built more
petite i don't i'm not saying he's pity
it's not a dem there's nothing i'm not
using that in the pejorative
he has thinner joints dak prescott has
thicker joints i know because
actually one of my best analytics people
in like the entire world works for the
cowboys and one of the reasons remember
we all didn't think jack was going to be
this monster getting this contract when
he was coming out of college my guy
told me this guy has the best ankles hip
hip and knees
we've seen he's in great shape to be
able to you know
sustain to sustain some hits even though
we have a good o-line
you know like it it's this is a guy who
can keep on getting hit
and is more durable so that's a really
strong indicator for success and coming
back from injury it doesn't mean it's
perfect
it doesn't mean it's right it just means
he has a higher probability of success
than other people because of his build
and you know that just gives him a
better
he'll have to do the work and obviously
with rehab and we all assume he's going
to do that right but
just his natural god-given god-given
body structure gives him an advantage
there you go cowboys fan tj you feel
feel good about that i didn't expect to
be talking about dax joints today but
yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're watching you you
watch them in the yeah you watch them in
pregame doing that little hip turn
yeah yeah you know cynthia
cynthia's put me at ease a little bit
i'll say that well let's go let's go
let's go down south a little bit further
uh new orleans
uh you know does the analytics bear out
for taysom hill as the guy or
uh or maybe a rejuvenated uh jameis
winston where is it where does it look
in there
for the saints quarterback position so
luckily it's sean payton who figures it
out
do i think like if i were talking about
fantasy football do i want to
i don't want to touch anyone on this
team or maybe even like many of their
past
i don't know who how to to navigate this
one yet i do think sean payton will cook
something up that we will all find
very interesting probably not
necessarily like
the one quarterback t some hill
situation not necessarily the
jameis winston situation because we saw
we know who jameis is he's
he's shown us he's he's got pluses and
he's got minuses
and what sean payton and coaches like
sean payton can do
are create opportunities for those
pluses to be accentuated and the minuses
to be sort of you know cushion and it
doesn't mean it's perfect it doesn't
mean it's right
i don't know exactly how it's all going
to net out there this could be a
trickier year to be a saints fan just in
general
but you always knew it would be after
drew brees there's always going to be
like some sort of difference and drop
off but i think it's going to look
it's going to be interesting and fun to
watch i don't know how effective it will
be in that division when you've got
a lot of i mean you've got tom brady in
that division and you know
maybe carolina will do something
interesting you know we don't know who
carolina's quarterback's gonna be so
they could
come out and surprise us but i i'll be
interested to see how it goes but i
think in that division
i think it could be less of a less of a
sure thing for the saints to make the
playoffs
all righty cynthia freeland from nfl
network uh analytics expert tell us a
little bit about your new clubhouse show
how people can view how people can be a
part of it
and uh talk to us a little bit about it
so every thursday 10 a.m
uh on the west and 1 p.m on the east and
basically like i'm trying to talk about
like we'll talk about football because
that's my home
but also talk about all the numbers that
you need to know and you can use
for the week so next week we'll get into
some masters and so maybe
my friend ryan leaf will come on and
talk to me about who he likes in golf
and can and related to numbers we did a
bunch of tournament numbers
and free agency kind of fall out this
past week some great different guests
from different sports just because
i've got all these numbers and they're
flying around and you know somebody
should make good use of them if i can
well good i will uh i'll definitely pay
attention to that if you're going to get
into the master stock
i have talked to uh rich eisen about
this
chris brockman and i going down as
analysts at augusta every year
to be on site perfect you know i think
it's a perfect fit
so uh i appreciate your i appreciate you
yeah like we could even we could like i
feel like you could set up at a hole and
like
you could you know interview like some
of the people that walk by you could
just like ask them random questions
because
i know that chris brockman's super funny
and people like super kind of unexpected
things like come out of his mouth so
that would be great i get his better
half
to give me uh to write me some roasts
and that's what i would do
yeah yeah all right everybody cynthia
freeland with her last year
favorite favorite uh cynthia freeland
everybody from the nfl network thanks
again sin
anytime hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here